[Music]  katy perry boards a plane in a  gingerbread costume well I love a theme  Katy was snapped in the get up along  with boyfriend orlando bloom as they  boarded a plane in van nuys california  now I'd keep it fun the couple continues  to debunk recent breakup rumors they  spent Thanksgiving together rocking cozy  pjs as they got ready to eat turkey Katy  also took a moment of reflection on  Thanksgiving morning to speak in support  of standing rock and their protests of  Dakota axes pipeline sharing information  about the protests and writing during  this holiday and beyond let us stand in  solidarity with all those who are trying  to protect it I made a donation and I  hope you can too today  [Music]  you